well we have conducted the longest and
largest evacuation of any Western
Country and I would like to pay tribute
to everyone involved with it or whether
it's Armed Forces Personnel diplomats
border force staff and that has resulted
in over 1 500 people being evacuated the
vast majority of whom are British
Nationals or their eligible dependents
what we have seen over the past 24 hours
or so is a significant decline in the
British Nationals coming forward now
that's what you'd expect it's what's
happened with other countries so what we
are saying now is that people should
expect within the next 24 hours so by
six o'clock UK time tomorrow for us to
cease those flights but that means
you're going to abandon British citizens
who haven't made it in that time or who
were having problems as we're hearing
now getting relative Partners children
others out well I wouldn't accept that
characterization the first thing I would
say is that every single British
national that has come forward and their
eligible dependents has been put safely
onto a plane we are seeing those numbers
declining significantly and just like
other countries as those numbers decline
we have put an end date on this what I
would say is that even beyond that we
will maintain Consular support in Sudan
particularly at the exit route so both
to the north to south and particularly
Port Sudan itself but it's not the case
that everyone coming forward has been
able to get out we know of cases where
the original advice was you could bring
your partner and if you're a British
citizen you could bring your partner and
there would be discretion at the air
base for people to go out that hasn't
been happening there have been Partners
turned away so why are these people not
going to be brought out
we have been clear with our criteria all
the way through in respect of this what
we have said is that if you are a
British national so you have a British
passport or have an eligible dependent
and in particular children you will you
will be able to
get on a plane and and get out and
that's exactly what has happened what we
have seen over the past 24 hours or so
is a decline in those numbers so just
like other countries we're saying you've
still got another 24 hours to make your
way to the airport that gives us the
longest and largest evacuation of any
Western Country with over 1 500 people
evacuated the vast majority of whom are
British Nationals or they're eligible
dependents and I think that this is an
appropriate point that we have reached
but you said spouses as well could come
and the stipulation was with a Visa but
there was going to be a discretion at
the airport that isn't happening people
are coming with spouses who are not
being able to get on these planes
well it is the case that border force
staff are empowered to exercise
discretion
it is the case that we of course have
prioritized British Nationals people
have those passports and we have also
prioritized eligible dependents as you
would expect the British government
would say that eligible children should
be prioritized there remains that
discretion in respect of others and that
has been exercised there remains another
24 hours for people to make their way to
the airport to ensure that that they can
take advantage of this and it in its
totality what we have seen is that we've
had the largest and we've had the the
longest evacuation of any Western
Country in every eligible person that's
come forward has got on that plane
another group have had no discretion uh
exercised uh people are doctors working
in the NHS who have visas to be here who
are also being turned away are they not
people that we should be bringing out
well I'm I'm aware of the case that
you're describing and we are in touch
and engaging uh rapidly with the
Sudanese doctors Association to see what
further support we can provide for them
and there are many desperate people
still in Sudan British citizens will
still be there what do you say to them
in 24 hours time what should they do
well it has been the case that uh over
the past 24 hours the number of eligible
British Nationals coming to the airport
has declined significantly we we said we
said we said we said at the time to
those people during that ceasefire uh
window they should expect that the
flights would come to an end what we are
now saying to them is there is another
24 hours for people to be able to to
come forward and the foreign office is
setting out that people may have a range
of reasons why they choose to remain in
Sudan uh whether that's uh connections
they have in that country it may be the
case that people have gone to other
parts of Sudan and it will remain the
case that even after this period of time
we are maintaining Consular support at
the other exit routes and in particular
at Port Sudan so what's your advice
though to someone who is a British
citizen who misses this window now what
are they going to do what should they do
well my advice to to people is first of
all we have been very clear that this
would be a time limited operation we
gave a very clear signal over 24 hours
ago that people should expect that as
the ceasefire comes to an end we would
be winding down the number of flights we
are now saying to those people you have
another 24 hours if you're eligible to
make your way to the airport and we will
get you on a plane just as we have done
for every other person that has come
forward who is is eligible making it the
the longest and largest evacuation
effort of any uh Western Country and if
you say people should go to Port Sudan I
mean there's no evacuation from there
the British ship that might evacuate
people is thousands of kilometers away
in Bahrain it's in a different ocean
what we are saying to to people is you
have 24 hours still on top of what we
have already said in the longest and
largest evacuation effort of any Western
Country if you present yourself and
you're eligible at the airport we will
make sure that you get on a flight just
as we have done with everyone else but
it has been the case that over the past
24 hours the number of eligible people
has been declining